celebrated your first anniversary yeah
you and widget that's nice we found you
have beautiful most people have kind of
I'll say it kind of crappy footage of
their wedding you guys have beautiful
like film of your wedding
yeah what's and it's gorgeous looking
you obviously use like professional
cameras but what struck me the most is
after the vows most people just kiss you
two kissed and then did our own
handshake your own handshake yeah I mean
if you're familiar with you know the NBA
the NFL Major League Baseball everyone
has an elaborate handshake him and
LeBron have to this day like 87
handshakes
but like dude 47b and they're like and
so that's not a handshake oh and there's
no there's choreography like W I'll and
I think choreographed one like the time
that it takes to to rehearse the
handshakes they could be practicing
basketball better yet tug of war that's
probably why they lost it tug of war
they were all trying to high-five before
the competition up there out on the
corner you know and they lose I think we
have footage let's take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's true that you guys you built a
sports bar in your house yes I got to
know about that yes well we each got a
room that we could design ourselves
without the other person's input
he built a shoe vault a shoe vault a
shoe vault yeah a vault it just displays
all the shoes all of his shoes some of
his shoes are putting there's other
shoes and Swiss accounts there were
shoes parked all over the world no one
must ever know in case they'll never
find my other shoes pretty much I mean
it has special lighting it's all
measured perfectly for his shoes
I was like I want a sports bar I want I
want pony kegs and I want I want to be
able to you know on a Saturday afternoon
I don't want to do anything but sit back
have a cold one and watch my Nebraska
Cornhuskers play and so the whole room
is is an O Maj it's a basically Tom
Osborne and the Nebraska corner so wait
so what else is there in there there's
obviously there's television there's you
got the bar at a bar what else what we
have we have Galaga
pac-man miss pac-man miss pac-man oh
yeah that's my jam right there miss
pac-man
well you and you and Chris Bosh he's
addicted Chris Bosh is addicted to miss
pac-man yeah he lives he lives a few
doors down and like 2:00 a.m. is it
Chris is it Chris Bosh he'll be in your
basement at 2:00 a.m. what the front
door wanting in to get on the game and
then you heard those like embarrassing
MS Pakman I've given you here at startup
again and he'll be that he'll be down
there for like 5:00 6:00 in the morning
that's pretty fun yeah I think it'd be
great to have I want to come over and
play gotta feed him you know he's seven
feet tall like it comes with
responsibility how Chris Bosh you know
gimmicky and leave a pile of food yeah
I guess I'm sleep you sound like it's
Jurassic Park and you got a wasn't that
a great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]